hello I'm a nostalgia critic guy
remember it so you don't have to and
welcome to another rendition of old
versus new
seeing how we're so close to
Thanksgiving I thought be great if we
talked about a pair of Thanksgiving
movies you know because it's kind of
religious I think Moses cocked a turkey
once Africa it's a turn commands in 1956
one of the greatest directors of all
time sussel B DeMille made one of the
most famous films of all time the Ten
Commandments actually it was a remake of
his already popular epic from the 19th
ones I guess he just wanted to up the
epicness and I know I should probably do
an old versus new on these two films but
see how they both have the same director
I think it's kind of cheating the 56
version is of course considered a
classic and no major studio would dare
try to top it
that is until DreamWorks came along and
tried to tell the same story as an
animated musical interesting choice when
you hear Bible mixed with musical and
Disney style animation you automatically
think disaster but the Prince of Egypt
was actually a decent remake it wasn't
telling the exact same story it had
different angles a different scale and a
different spin on the main characters
and in my opinion is a very underrated
animated film but still which one holds
up the best the original classic or the
anime reimagining well let's dive right
into the land of milk and honey that
would be nice but I'm talking about the
movies this is old versus new Ten
Commandments versus the principie
it's hard to find someone to play one of
the most holy people in all of the Bible
don't let you settle for the human from
Planet of the Apes and ice man from Top
Gun so let's take a look at best Moses
like many of the elements in this
comparison these two performances
couldn't be any more different Charlton
Heston's Moses is very much like a
prodigy even before he speaks with God
let your own image proclaim my loyalty
for a thousand years who would take a
throne by force that is earned by deeds
or Val Kilmer's Moses is seen much more
as the everyman the person who fell into
his leadership rather than seeking it
out I wish the Prince of Egypt the son
of the man who slaughtered their
children you you've chosen the wrong
messenger how can I even speak to these
people both do very well and convey
exactly what they need to convey so
really just depends on which Moses you
like better the everyman or the Superman
for me personally I enjoy Heston's
performance a little more the reason
being that he has an unbelievable amount
of confidence when you see Heston as the
Prince of Egypt you immediately want to
be like strong and powerful but also
kind and wise I warn you most of the
temple grain belongs to the gods what
the gods can digest when that's sour in
the belly of a slave everything he says
has such weight to it he was destined
for greatness even before he found his
true calling if you were told this guy
was gonna be your leader you follow him
in a heartbeat okay you'd recommend a
good hair salon first but you would
follow city is built of brick Pharaoh
the strong make many the starving make
few that dead make none
the animated Moses struts out more like
a rambunctious young man like a college
student who crashed his dad's car father
the fault is mine I go did Rama seize on
and so I am responsible this isn't bad
though as it shows by the end just how
far he's come in leadership I guess in a
way you could argue that this makes it
more human and again there's nothing
wrong with it as Moses was human or was
he
but Heston I found was just more
interesting because you feel like there
was a greatness in him from the start
and when you see it realized it's all
the more influential though granted his
speech can at times be a little stilted
and dare I say it
preachy listen uh no no God we bring you
the Word of God and you shall know that
God is God what Kingdom has sent you the
kingdom of the Most High beeyotch both
do very well but I think Heston gets the
point in this round
even though Kilmer's is more human and
sympathetic Heston sort of represents
the will and strength that all good
people can possess and that's pretty
hard to pull off
plus he's the only Moses where you
actually know his last name
Oh Moses Moses Moses Moses Moses Moses
Moses Moses yeah I think you didn't know
Moses his last name was also Moses did
you it's just like that other movie um
Maya Mario and Luigi Maya don't start
with me one goes to ten commands I
didn't mean to cause you more pain
but what about the villain ramasees is
one of the greatest villains of all time
but did you know that him and Moses were
brothers
he didn't oh sorry I didn't know this is
the best fantasies
again these two are very different
performances yul brenner plays ramasees
has very cold hearted caring nothing for
his brother or anyone else except his
legacy here is your kingdom the scorpion
the Cobra and the lizard for subjects
read them if you will leave the Hebrews
to me water oh well where he finds plays
Ramos eats as a product of his
environment a tortured soul who still
loves his brother but is also under the
psychological grip of his overbearing
father one weak link can break the chain
of a mighty dynasty I will not be the
weak link because of this the ramasees
in Prince of Egypt comes across as more
tragic
you know why he's making his decisions
and how much it destroys him inside to
declare war on his own brother why could
things be the way they were before look
at this scene for example this is one of
the best bits of animation I've ever
seen it's just as Moses tells ramasees
that he hasn't returned to be his
brother but rather he's returned to be
his enemy the whole gamut of emotions is
ran here I can no longer hide in the
desert while they suffer at your hands
sadness anger regret frustration and
vengeance all in just 40 seconds that's
pretty impressive the Rama season 10
commandments is good too but in a
different way he's likable because of
how despicable he is he's cunning he's
manipulative and he doesn't care who
knows it just look at how he talks to
the woman who will one day be his wife I
could never
does that matter you will be my wife
will come to me whenever I call you I
will enjoy that very much what a
dickhole
there's pre-caching of rage that's
brought out of this performance but
still I gotta say refined version is
better he's simply more complex and
sympathetic but he can also be just as
menacing as well
- shall be a great cry in all of Egypt
such as never has been or ever will be
again it's a juicy formas right out of
Shakespeare and he's portrayed just
perfectly they pull you into the drama
by pulling us into his drama having the
Jews between family and legacy just
about everything you could possibly want
in a character is in this performance
and I think that's more than point
worthy point goes to Prince of Egypt
does that matter
now comes the real hard part the
supporting cast both these films had a
gigantic cast of celebrities and all of
them were absolutely wonderful but which
one was better let's take a look
talk about starstruck both these movies
had a bajillion celebrities in their
lineup 10 commandments had ever G
Robinson Vincent Price and Baxter John
Carradine and that's just to name a few
Prince of Egypt had Patrick Stewart Jeff
Goldblum Sandra Bullock Michelle
Pfeiffer again that's just to name a few
so which cast was better well again
they're very different Prince of Egypt
has fewer cast members but they're given
much more development Miriam and Aaron
for example are pushed out much more
with Moses his real brother and sister
and Moses's wife sapore has given a lot
more screen time as well having them
meet before he actually leaves his crown
since Ten Commandments is longer they're
allowed to look at even more characters
like in this version Moses has a son we
never even saw a son in Prince of Egypt
unless you've somewhere in the back the
slimey servant of Ramses isn't in Prince
of Egypt either unless you count Steve
Martin and Martin Short as the high
priests ramasees wife was one of the
most interesting characters in the movie
is left out of Prince of Egypt - what's
the better payoff then is it good to
have fewer characters and more
development or the other way around well
for the most part Ten Commandments comes
off as stronger because even though they
have more characters they have great
actors to portray them because of this
the relatively short scene still get
across how sympathetic or unsympathetic
they are the Egyptian that Moses murders
is much more satisfying when you see
that it's Vincent Price playing him
you instantly see scumbag and he doesn't
even have to do them that's just the
power of Vincent Price you make no
outcry Joshua but you will you will cry
for the mercy of death
from our humiliation and discomfort
mm-hmm the same can be said for ever
Gene Robinson look how cocky he is in
revealing the secret of Moses's past
people with a sword up to his thumb he
has nothing to fear
he deliverer is Moses
he's Hebrew the son of slaves I will pay
your price like I said they're not all
given small roles
ramasees wife is very complex choosing
between the man she loves and the man
she marries only to find her life
destroyed by Moses and left with the
emptiness of her vengeful husband look
at this scene he's about to cut her to
ribbons after failing to get Moses until
before you strike show me his blood on
your sword
bastard can't even do it maybe he's
ashamed of his failure maybe he just
figures it's crueler to leave her alive
but he knows that killing her will bring
him nothing only a bitch so simple and
yet so complex can cause such a reaction
and I think that's what makes 10
commandments stand out more the
harshness they portray a world that's
advanced but also savage where great
monuments are made but death is common
and seen all the time a world that needs
a savior like Moses to intervene we get
some of that harshness in Prince of
Egypt with Steve Martin and Martin Short
but they seem out of place it's a little
too gimmicky and for lack of a better
word cartoony you're in trouble yeah
just get down here fine the Prince of
Egypt cast is still sympathetic but this
cast is just so fascinating and how
cutthroat they are they get across a lot
with very little and even though I still
love the cast in Prince of Egypt the
cast in Ten Commandments is just darker
and more interesting pie goes to the ten
commands you shame yourself
and now the big one the one that I
thought I'd never be able to judge god I
am going to judge God balls-to-the-wall
people this is the best God
so yeah I'll admit it's a little weird
comparing gods as opposed to like before
it just sort of depends on your
interpretation are you a god-fearing fan
or a not god-fearing fact as far as the
story goes the 10 commandments God is
probably the one most people would think
about when hearing it I mean this is the
guy who sent flaming ale constant
darkness and killed all the firstborn in
short this was a badass God so they
provided him with a deep badass voice do
this in my name or you will get a cap in
your ass seriously you're like a bug I
can't just be like and you're gone don't
mess it up I am badass God in Prince of
Egypt we give more of the warm loving
God that many people have favored over
the past several years take the staff
you have Moses
with it you shall do my wonders
in my opinion that the prints of each of
God is a little more clever and
well-thought-out
just look at the burning bush it looks
like something not of this world but
also something that can be soothing and
comforting the one in the ten
commandments looks more like a cartoon
than well the actual cartoon it also
makes the clever choice of having the
voice of Moses be the voice of God you
can read a lot into that and come up
with some fun conclusions as to why were
you I am that I am I might uh say the
one in ten commandments again is the
deep traditional booming voice that
while impressive doesn't sound that
loving like I said as the story of
smoting goes this God is probably closer
to what most people think of but the
soft kind God is a much more interesting
contrast and you still feel the size and
divinity when he appears and all comes
down to personal preference but this God
simply seems more like the God of love
and peace than this one does point goes
to the Prince of Egypt
it's all tied up and we come down to the
most important element the story this is
story for the win
now logically you would think that
because 10 commandments is longer it has
more time to tell a better complex story
let's really look at this 10
commandments is a complex story with a
lot of drama going on but there's
several things they overlooked for
example it seems to forget that Moses
and ramasees grew up together that they
were technically brothers I know they're
trying to portray ramasees as the bad
seed but if you were never told that
these two were brothers you probably
never would have guessed it there's no
love in their eyes no memory of the good
times that they had when Moses shows up
after years of being gone Ramses is just
like whatever piss off in Prince of
Egypt the heart of the entire story is
around the fact that they're brothers
when moses arrives he has no idea how
ran disease is going to react and he
reacts like any brother would Moses the
focus of the story seems to be on their
relationship and it really works you
feel the pain both of them are going
through and how much they wish they
could return to what they had this makes
the drama much more interesting I also
like how more visual Prince of Egypt is
I mean yeah Ten Commandments looks
unbelievable the Prince of Egypt really
used the visuals to its advantage not
just because it's animated but because
they also do things differently like
compare these scenes back to Bank where
Moses tells his wife about seeing God
the original is done very well and a lot
of his portrayed just threw Charlton
Heston's expressions but in Prince of
Egypt there's no dialogue at all I like
that you have to guess exactly what he's
telling her the music almost tells the
story for us and her reaction of taking
it all in is just perfect you really
feel the emotion of this scene there's
also some scriptural problems the Prince
of Egypt works with - like in Ten
Commandments Moses turns his staff into
a snake but then the high priests do the
exact same thing isn't the idea in both
the Bible and this movie that there's
only one God how did they change those
things then is it it's the snake just
add water in Prince of Egypt it's a bit
more clever all the tricks that the
priests perform are done with smoke and
mirrors there's a blinding light when
the staffs are transformed so you could
make the argument that they switch them
while nobody could see now that's a
really clever way out
the songs themselves surprisingly really
help to tell the story - not only do
they move it along but they also show
the characters are going through as well
as enhance both the joy and suffering
that everyone has to deal with though I
will admit at times they do seem a
little sporadic many nights we've prayed
dude all the first phones are dead hey
let's show tunes don't get me wrong the
expressing of emotions and 10
commandments is good too but at times it
seems a little soap opera Sh
I mean yeah this is heavy-duty stuff
that they're dealing with but something
about the way they hold themselves and
speak to one another does seem like a
bit much forgive me
and yes Prince of Egypt does have this
problem sometimes - there's just some
moments that feel really forced like the
comedy in the first half of the movie it
never really feels that natural father
will kill me don't worry nobody will
even notice us coming in nobody will
even notice the best comedic moments
were the ones that actually added to the
drama like the desperation in Goldblum's
voices Aaron while trying to stop his
sister from revealing who they really
are you you must know careful slave oh
my good Prince
um she's exhausted from the day's work
uh not that it was too much we we quite
enjoyed it but but she's confused
but even the bad comedy helps generate
the kind of corniness of nostalgia and
let's be honest nostalgia can be corny
it's a pleasant time you want to return
to where everything seems simpler and
this works in Prince of Egypt because
they're creating a great contrast to the
later drop the few corny moments and ten
commandments just come out as corny and
don't really add anything in the long
run the corniness comes from how
overdramatic it is now how funny is
trying to be because of this
surprisingly the animated musical seems
to be the more dramatic film does it
have problems sure are there elements
from the original they are better
absolutely but on the whole prints of
each of knew that the focus had to be on
the brothers that's where the drama
comes from and that's where the most
interesting conflict takes place they
knew that that was the most fascinating
element that's where people can
sympathize the most it makes us realize
why the story is so good it brings out
good characters from good writing from a
good story so it turns out the winner is
Prince of Egypt the superior film trend
from the fierce wrath Oh Lord
and that's all I got thanks for joining
me mr. mojo critic this is gone God like
what like V God yes I heard what you
were saying about me being a loving God
or vengeful God yeah you are on I'm a
vengeful God Oh
your ass is grass
I'm the Nostalgia Critic I remember it
so you don't have to
you
Oh Moses Moses